foreign
although this program is made in 1982
the information contained in it
has not been presented in the
establishment media
the cia's greatest operation without any
qualifications it's better than in terms
of their interest than when they install
the shah in power
it's better than the coup in guatemala
and of course their many failures from
their own point of view better than
putting pinochet in power in terms of ci
values
what it is is nothing less than an
official secrets act this is the the
legislation that the cia has been trying
for 30 years to get to give it
legal protection and legal exemption
from freedom of speech and freedom of
the press
we'll begin to learn what it's like to
live in a third world country which is
being targeted by the c i a
many americans
have lost sight of the fact that many
citizens of other countries particularly
in the third world
have been the victims of massive cia
operations covert operations
everything from recruitment
to bribery to buying of an election
on up the line to paramilitary
activities and terrorism training and
torture and even assassination and
overthrowing of of governments
and i think that americans
fail to
realize this until it starts sometimes
to hit them at home and that's
apparently what's going to be
happening now and legally
john stockwell former high c i a
official
and
lewis wolf co-editor of covert action
information bulletin tonight on
alternative views
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
although glasnost is occurring in the
soviet union we still have not had
glasnost in the united states concerning
the subjects which we'll discuss on
alternative views
good evening glad you're with us tonight
on alternative views this is a very
special treat because we have two very
very prominent people in the world of
covert activity
experts in their field and nice people
too that's a strange combination but
we've got them
we have john stockwell back with us
john was a key official in the cia
for several years before quitting and
writing about his experiences in the
book on company business
his most recent book is a novel entitled
red sunset
also going to do something special
tonight a few weeks ago we
did an interview with lewis wolf who's
one of the editors of covert action
information bulletin now this is one of
the bulletins which
really has been freaking out the cia for
many years because it
does name names of agents but that's
just one of the things it does it has a
lot of stories about covert activity
and some overt activity of intelligence
organizations and semi-intelligence
organizations around the world so you'll
find out what happens with coups and
various types of activities like this
around the world by reading covert
action information bulletin well we were
going to have john with us where to do
the interview with lewis wolf but john
is out of town so what we're going to do
is the next best thing we're going to
show segments of the interview we did
with lewis wolfe and then we'll have
john comment on them
lewis and his colleagues since 1978 have
been publishing articles exposing the
various operations of the cia all over
the world and some of the threats to
civil liberties and democracy that this
organization has contained lewis welcome
to alternative news thank you i'm glad
to be here first of all how did you get
into the cia
watch
business and what led you and your
colleagues to found the covert action
information bulletin
well i've been
a journalist since the 1960s and
actually 1966 i spent nine years in
southeast asia
and it was really there that i first
came to grips with what the cia does in
the world
that its main function as i learned at
that time in laos in the philippines is
intervening covertly in the affairs of
other countries and in fact covert
action by the cia's own definition is
activity secret activity which can be
carried out without the
knowledge of the targets of that
activity being able to learn that it was
carried out by the cia or in fact by the
u.s government
and what led you and your colleagues to
found the covert action information
bulletin when did you begin to do this
well it was
after a long succession of efforts
largely growing out of the watergate
revelations
of the church committee and pike
committee reports even the rockefeller
commission reports which documented
gross and ongoing and very large scale
cia covert activities that had been
carried out up till that time the
american people didn't know very much
about this
and that was really what the cia is
about is keeping it secret from the
american people
in in in some the cia's activities of
course are known to the people who
against whom they're carried out but
it's the american people who are the
last to know about it
and we
as a result of a lot of those
revelations
and a lot of other people who were
concerned about it decided to try and
put together a journalistic effort to
look into these areas there was a
another magazine counter spy which
started
earlier
and after several years it it
bit the dust and we decided after two
years in 1978 to start covert action
information bulletin
well it looks like there's going to be
some real problems coming up not only
just for you and covert action
information bulletin
but also for civil liberties in general
in the united states and finding out
what's happening what our government is
doing in our name covertly around the
world with the intelligence
identities protection act just about to
be passed in congress and with reagan's
executive order 12-33
things are going to be quite different
shortly aren't they
there is clearly a a
very
marked escalation towards secrecy in
this government
these two pieces of
one legislation and one executive order
the executive order does not have to be
propounded by congress congress doesn't
have a
single word to say about it
basically these two working in tandem
with each other
along with other
efforts by this administration to
[Music]
embed the cia and the other intelligence
agencies of which there are some 18
federal agencies
in secrecy
this bill is the cia's greatest
operation without any qualifications
it's better than in terms of their
interest than when they install the shah
in power
it's better than the coup in guatemala
and of course their many failures from
their own point of view better than
putting pinochet in power in terms of ci
values
what it is is nothing less than an
official secrets act this is the the
legislation that the cia has been trying
for 30 years to get to give it
legal protection and legal exemption
from freedom of speech and freedom of
the press
now what makes it such a beautiful
operation is that it is in the process
of being
passed it's going through the congress
more or less like a dose of the salts
with the senate voted on it a couple of
months ago
the vote was something like 92
and the house it's expected to pass by a
similar majority
and yet the american people by and large
including media people including
television interviewers across the
nation and journalists are oblivious
that it's even passing much less what it
really means
now what it really means see it's
couched and what makes it such a typical
and beautiful ci operation
is that it's couched in the terms
of protecting our agents who are out in
the cold risking their lives to defend
the country this is senator benson was
the original sponsor of this bill by the
way and this was what he said about it
in many speeches here in texas now it's
passed to
senator john chafee and jake garn
sponsoring the bill
in washington now who can argue with
that legal protection from our agents
whose names are being exposed by
irresponsible people who don't agree
with the government's policies
now
if the facts were that simple if those
were the true facts who could argue with
it but the truth is that these agents
lives are not in danger because of their
names being exposed the truth is that
these agents are functioning from
embassies with diplomatic passports
under circumstances
in which if the worst possibly happens
and they're absolutely caught
buying secrets from some local spy agent
a minister in the government or whatnot
the worst that will be will happen to
them even in the soviet union is that
they will be asked to leave the country
under no circumstances will they ever be
attacked
or jailed or executed or what not
by the government another government by
the host government where they're living
and breaking all the local laws by being
a secret agent and and recruiting spies
and inducing people to commit treason
now in in the four or five posts that i
served in overseas full-time we had
full liaison with the president of the
country the chief of the police and all
the police officers and all the military
officers this means that we met with
them weekly in the name of the ci no
secrets to have lunch or dinner and
exchange information and do favors for
each other if there were ever a
terrorist attack or threat against one
of us the first thing we would do would
be to pick up the telephone and call the
local police chief and say hey there's a
threat against us and i might note that
this would this would also apply in the
soviet union
if there were terrorist threat in moscow
against the us embassy or a us case
officer ci man they would call the local
police and say you know somebody's about
to blow us up there is a brotherhood
of secret quote
secret police agents that functions like
a brotherhood even when they're
supposedly on the other side they're
competing but it's sort of like
professional football players they're on
different different teams but they're
still professional football players well
you had buddies who were kgb
played tennis with them played chess
with them socialized with them went
drinking with them and that was the sop
for all case officers everywhere
two thousand plus well over two thousand
names have been revealed printed
published in the last few years and not
one agent
has been killed because of his name
being revealed now there were two cases
where it looked like they were put up
jobs one and one which the congressman
and the cia always mentioned is the
reason why they jumped on richard welch
in athens uh the 18th of december in
1975 was killed
he was
shot up by terrorists in front of his
home and at that moment the church
committee which was in full session
was out of business washington every
door in washington closed on the church
committee because as though the church
investigation had anything whatsoever to
do with it they flew him back and gave
him a full
state ceremony which of course was
admission that he was cia to the world i
mean the headlines were ci chief kill
they didn't say the third secretary of
embassy killed the united states
government made as much politics as they
could out of the fact that this man was
a career diplomat agent
now the fact was they caught the
terrorists that killed him
and they they
ascertain they verified that those were
the individuals who had published his
name in an athens newspaper three days
before they killed him because they
wanted world attention to what they were
doing
and it had nothing to do with the
investigations or publications in
washington and they already planned to
kill him now this man had been ordered
by ci security to change houses because
he was living in the same house
that eight other ci station chiefs had
lived in before him generation after
generation after generation after
generation of ci station chiefs had
lived in that same mansion it was a big
villa in a very posh part of athens as
governments had changed coups the
colonel's coups
the monarchy in and out of power much
earlier and dealing with all of the
terrorist activities and anti-terrorist
activities and coups in the middle east
from athens with the ci heavily involved
with each government and change of
government and the ins and outs in these
governments and yet the cia station
chief was living in the same house
throughout eventually he was killed he
refused to move because he said it was a
good house now there is no way that that
can be blamed on u.s journalists
publishing names in washington moreover
as i pointed out the cia the cia
director bill colby exploited that man's
death to make a big issue and to
effectively close down the church
committee
that was investigating the cia which was
investigating
the ci's extensive malpractices they put
the church committee on the defensive
and out of business now there was one
other incident in el salvador where two
agents who were under a labor cover
uh were killed by
right wing by the government uh police
the secret plea they're treasury agents
is it in in el salvador that do the the
killing down there now these
uh these two guys were in contact with
the government they were killed by
government agents set up in a hotel in
shot
and the united states announced to the
world that they were secret agents their
names had been published much previously
but the united states identified them
thereby admitting they were agents and
admitting that they were using this
labor organization as cover where did
they make this announcement they did it
the prosecuting attorney the state the
state department's representative in the
passport case in which they took
philadel's passport away from him
revealed the identities of these agents
and claimed that that proved that people
publishing names led to their death they
were already dead when the government
chose to use a totally
fictitious a totally false ploy to
discredit phil agee he had not revealed
their names and so it's now in the
supreme court records it's cited by the
supreme court justices in their decision
against phil agee and his passport
him keeping his passport these agents
being killed i.e the supreme court and
the state department reveal their
identities to accomplish their objective
against philadelphi
there's another situation in
jamaica where it looked like it was a
planned put up
in that case indeed
the chief of station's
house was shot up with machine gun
bullets and so they made a
considerable propaganda publicity
out of that with photographs of the
bullets but what it's true his name had
been published but what happened is
the back wall of his garage well away
from the house received five machine gun
bullets at a time when his family was
out of the country and he was not in the
house
and yet they tried to use that to make
publicity to show that it made it
dangerous to have the names revealed it
was also during an election where the
opposition to the social democratic
government wanted to make it appear that
terrorism was rampant in jamaica and so
wasn't there some political exploitation
oh indeed there was considerable
political exploitation of it and and all
evidence points that it was it was the
the government seek uh secret police
that fired the bullets right but but
again the the press in washington played
this as played cooperated with the ci to
give publicity uh for
for the bill against the exposing of
names there's no real need for the bill
it's not protected in any way or
national security that's not required by
the history of the cia precisely on the
one hand that's the problem and i i go a
bit further to point out
that
these agents
80 of them were identified from overt
information in the library of congress
the people publishing the covert action
information bulletin go to the library
of congress and go through the state
department's overt records of its
personnel and come up with the ci
officers names infallibly because there
are little indicators in there which you
or you or you anyone can go in and read
through and say that ci and that's ci
and that ci plus isn't it just generally
known in most cia stations who is cia
don't they find themselves to be known
we used to call it contacts and
information we used to call it wearing
an invisible badge
you you acted as though you had a badge
ci up here you you drew people to you
imci talked to me you were taught to do
this allen dulles and the original ci
great in his book the craft of
intelligence makes this point that you
have to be known to be an effective
intelligence
officer
but see that's on the one hand the bill
is is not necessary
and it's dishonest in that sense it's
based on false premises on the other
hand the bill is so written that it goes
far beyond the protection of agents
names for example
the bill is so written that it will be a
felony for agents names to be published
even if they're already
to republish the names even if they've
already been published as in the library
of congress or anywhere else it also
includes activities of agents so that
you can
if an agent kicks in the door of your
house and rapes your wife or whatever
and you publish a story about it without
citing the name it would still be a
felony under the executive order
so we have to see both the executive
order and the intelligence identities
bill
as almost part of a package
uh
under the executive order the cia now
will be allowed and is allowed since it
was signed in december by the president
it is now law
the cia will be allowed to carry out
covert activities in the united states
as well as the all the other agencies
too
so that if you were to discover for
example that a member of an intelligence
agency had infiltrated say your church
organization your student organization
trade union
or whatever organization
or any group of more than two people
was infiltrated and you discovered this
and you so much as mentioned it to a
friend without even writing a news
article or without even talking about it
on the media
on television for example you could be
held criminally liable under this bill
and we're talking about a bill which
authorizes or which penalizes persons
and
for 15 years in prison
i'm sorry five years in prison
fifteen thousand dollar fine or both
for persons who've never worked in the
government and that that's a pretty
heavy price to have to pay to
try and hold up your rights to stand up
for your rights against the onslaught of
the intelligence agencies now the new
york times to give you the the proof of
the the the argument that this is an
official secrets act the new york times
in questioning the sponsors of the bill
on the floor of the senate pointed out
that as it was written
if the london times published a story
about ci activities and the station
chief some scandal of some kind the new
york times couldn't republish the london
times story without committing a felony
and the sponsor of the bill slapped his
hand on the table and said that's right
we want to knock off all this criticism
of the cia so the situation this has
already come up with the revelation of
cia activity in iran recently which was
not published in the united states for
very long but eventually it got either
washington post or the new york times
did it and there was a big uproar
because they were publishing it
and the in the last hearings the new
york times
uh
questioning again senator chafee about
this bill said that as they read it they
would not be able to publish their very
legitimate and valuable stories about
the activities of cia agents ed wilson
and frank turple who were selling
terrorist technology to libya after they
left the cia without committing a felony
and senator chafee said yes in the
future the washington post and the new
york times will have to be careful what
they publish about the cia i should say
if this bill had been law then we would
have never known about watergate
absolutely
uh
but now it will be clear to many more
americans that there is a sort of a
split-level foreign policy as there is a
split-level policy at home there is the
rhetoric and then there is the reality
and
with secrecy
in their best pocket they can now carry
out a lot of these activities
and do it as they say legally
and what's once more we're going back to
the the age
of almost the cowboy politics that the
cia carried out in the 50s and 60s they
claim
as a result of the church committee and
other
revelations that they don't do that
anymore
well this administration is not only
not saying that but they're saying that
it's now legal and now they're being
very up front about covert activity in
many cases the covert activities are now
being overt activities he's been talking
about the cia being the main
focus of this bill but it isn't just the
cia it's the fbi where they're involved
in quote
anti-terrorist activities and of course
reagan has said anybody who dissents is
a terrorist and involved in
disinformation that's no exaggeration
that's great
and
also any of the other government or
military intelligence organizations
i think many americans as a result of
these two
matters and others also
will begin to learn what it's like to
live in a third world country which is
being targeted by the cia
many americans
have lost sight of the fact that many
citizens of other countries particularly
in the third world
have been the victims of massive cia
operations covert operations
everything from recruitment
to bribery to buying of an election
uh on up the line to paramilitary
activities and terrorism training and
torture and even assassination and
overthrowing of of governments
and i think that americans
fail to realize this until it starts
sometimes to hit them at home and that's
apparently what's going to be
happening now and legally this
administration makes no bones that it
wishes to
that it sees its own people
many of us
as the enemy
and in fact there are many people i
think in in the country who consider
themselves very middle of the road who
would be opposed to this it it is
absolutely incompatible with our system
of government as we have known it in the
past moreover it's written to include
obviously more than the cia that was the
all government agencies that have a
right to secrecy will be included in
this thing john this is literally
unconstitutional though this is
absolutely unconstitutional it seems to
us that
there are people in congress who are
prepared to
relegate
the first amendment to a lower priority
and they are more interested in what
they call national security
one member of congress
as well as one deputy director of of the
cia
once stated that the first amendment
that's only an amendment
seems to me that's a rather
shocking description of one of the
hallmarks of of our constitution this is
why i call it their greatest operation
is they're doing it without a
constitutional amendment
which is beautiful in itself it is if
they propose to have all the states
ratify a bill saying throw out freedom
of speech and freedom of the press and
give the ci it would never pass but on
the one hand they're doing it without
constitutional amendments and and two
they're doing it without the nation even
being aware of it which says something
about the vigilance of americans
and and their own feelings about their
freedom of speech and press they could
care less they would rather up watch a
football game why is this the case or
why have they gotten so far with it
without media scrutiny without public
uproar etc it's not just the apathy of
the people listen it also the media just
hasn't reported
on what's involved in this well the
media in this country is is and is the
most apathetic that i've ever seen in
the world in terms of playing
uh ball with the administration 80
percent of our news is reporting
quotations of political leaders
president reagan giving a speech in
which everything he says is either
distortions of historical fact or are
propaganda statements in effect
all mixed together and yet the press
will report
his speech
as a fact it is a fact he made a speech
he said those words but they they don't
say at the end and everybody in the room
that it was all boulder dash now there's
a little bit more of that with reagan
than there was with other presidents
because he makes these misstatements so
constantly he gets the facts
screwed up so much but the press doesn't
have any sense of defending its own
rights we have had an occasional
editorial including in the austin
american statesman saying that the names
of agents bill is unfortunate
and that's about the size the new york
times ran an editorial saying this is
unfortunate
they said it was kind of it was kind of
wistful i read it when i was on my way
to lecture at yale and wesleyan a couple
of months ago and i read it the new york
times they were saying
golly gee whiz they mean this thing to
apply to us too
there was another in which they
mentioned louis wolfe and they said well
it's a bad bill but on the other hand
we've got to take care of people like
lewis wolf and maybe john stockwell they
cannot
believe
that the this that such a thing will
actually apply to them but
unfortunately the cia has many allies in
congress and some even in the media
and so sometimes you can pick up a
newspaper and read some of the cia's own
propaganda
coming from from some of those people
what is the source of the cia's power in
washington well i think it's the whole
idea that the cia has
built up
even in the halls of congress that it is
somehow a sacred entity
and that
while there was a lot of criticism
of j edgar hoover and the fbi
not a whole lot of it while he was alive
it's all happened since he died
um
it's interesting because it is known for
example that hoover had a lot of
information and a lot of
very damaging information against
members of congress
it is also clear that the cia
maintains relations with a number of
congress people who have some of whom
have said so on the floor of congress
that
they
are in close contact with the cia and
this bill for example which was written
by the cia and they said so deputy
director frank carlucci said it on
national television back in 1978 and
said we are now about to deliver this
bill up to to congress
that's a little bit of a strange way for
laws to be written if they're going to
be written by the cia now what this bill
is it's part of a number of bills and
legal precedents that the government is
obtaining
to keep now they're not going to go out
and arrest the editor of the new york
times and put him in jail for 10 years
the week after this bill is passed
they're not that stupid but they're
getting they may arrest lou wolf if he
violates it i think they probably would
because they could make propaganda
out of such an arrest but what they're
they're doing is they're getting that
bill they're getting
the passport ruling for example
they're getting the other legal
precedent such as the lawsuit against
frank snep marketing myself
and travel restrictions they're getting
authority for the secretary of state to
throw people out of the country who
should have political exile here such as
the el salvadorian refugees
and they're getting these things ready
so that the next war that they get us
into as in vietnam they will have the
legal
power muscle to handle it differently
than they did during the vietnam war
they handled the centered home to make
it impossible to speak out the descent
that choked off kissingers and nixon's
and before that rusk's
efforts in vietnam the dis the popular
uprising at home that forced the united
states government to abandon its
policies and plans in vietnam will not
be
nearly
the government will have weapons to
crush such a thing in the future it'll
have an official secrets act to make it
illegal to publish stories like milai
and whatnot because they were obviously
secret agents involved so the
publication of the mili stories would be
a felony jane fonda and cora weiss's
travels to try to make communication and
establish some basis for working out a
peaceful solution to the thing they
would snap their passports up in the
future and and then the other
restrictions on travel
the other restrictions on government
agents so that
an officer has been in the service
can't stop and say we were bombing
villages and bombing churches and
schools that would be a felony he would
go to jail it's a british official
secrets act with a different name you
know you were mentioning a while ago
it's not only just the cia but it's
others too we had a program recently
which you may remember
about the greensboro massacres in which
the clan and the nazis
in broad daylight and in front of tv
cameras shot down five
labor organizers and killed them in
greensboro north carolina
it came out by the investigations that
bureau of alcohol tobacco firearms
agents was working with the nazis indeed
he was the one who gave them the names
of the people to be shot
also there was fbi and local police
complicity with the klan members as a
matter of fact it's come out that the
fbi itself established over 40 chapters
of the klan over the years in north
carolina alone
these revelations would be a felony now
yeah
exactly this passes it would be a felony
to reveal such information to the
american public or government of buy and
for the people is is soon to be a thing
of the past in the united states what
this will do is to put the cia the fbi
and these other government agencies
outside of the realm of public criticism
and even discussion
or law
yeah outside of the law because they've
broken every law of man and god
in in the activities they have conducted
the the experimentation on american
citizens for example with chemicals and
disease the propaganda of the united
states breaking and entering colonel
white's famous words about where else
can a red-blooded boy lie kill cheat
steal rape and pillage in the name of
the all-highest now they will be able to
that was who was this this was colonel
george m white one of the founders of
the cia who eventually directed the
mk ultra program
and he was retiring
he and i overlapped by about four years
he came out of retirement to address my
mid-career seminar and a telling about
how we put the cia together and we did
this and the other in his letters
memoirs he wrote and then allowed it to
be published that statement where else
could a red-blooded american boy lie
kill cheat steal rape and pillage with
the blessings of the all highest
and
that was before they had an official
secrets act to protect their activity
john there's been very few people in
this country that have actually told us
what the cia has been up to and exposed
some of their misdeeds etc you of course
and a few other former agents have
written some books and given lectures
criticizing agents activities this would
be impossible in the future would it not
be we will never know
uh the truth and the details the blood
and gore the extent
of
of responsibility and culpability
for the ci's program in nicaragua
right now
unless someone like reagan or in his
administ a top official chooses to stand
up
and denounce what's happening because
top officials are exempt from these laws
but we will never know the truth about
for example the shah and the evacuation
of iran
and which was a debacle i was told
by a friend of mine who who
who was close to a third friend of mine
who was part of the cia security
establishment in iran who said it was a
debacle that far exceeded the evacuation
of vietnam
the evacuation of the united states from
from iran
and
this this story will never come out and
the many other stories the
assassinations
that probably are being planned today
such such as the coup in in el in chile
or the assassination of patrice lumumba
these sort of things are going on but
the public won't know about them in the
future
why has the government been so outraged
by this publication and putting so much
heat on them i don't think there's any
other publication in america that's had
so much government pressure put on them
then well you have two forces in the
government functioning here you have one
is
an a defensive outrage against being
attacked
secret police organizations don't like
to be exposed and attacked that's the
same anger that they focused at me
people who are
performing activities that the the full
range of the society the 90 percent of
the society would describe as depraved
people who are doing this while
functioning under the cover of being
legitimate state department diplomats
prestigious cover positions don't like
to have their activities and names
published for what they really are
this is traditional anywhere in the
world the goon squads in chile don't
like to be attacked nor does the kgb in
in russia to be attacked and exposed but
nowhere else in the world do they become
as self-righteous and as vindictive as
they do in washington
where they they
the united states ambivalence the
duplicity the the the jekyll and hyde
aspect of the united states character
where we profess such high ideals and
yet traditionally we have
ex
exploited we we have engaged in
activities that included dropping atom
bombs on women and children in japan
eliminating large elements of the indian
population of this country and in the
past thirty years killing
well over eight hundred thousand people
in the third world under circumstances
that can only be called terrorism
but doing it pretending all the while to
be
idealistic high-minded human rights
oriented freedom-loving people
now
these values are brought together in the
cia where people are diplomats by cover
and cia agents
by trade and when they have themselves
exposed and have their children their
family their friends find out that hey
you weren't really a nice diplomat all
these years you were in fact running the
phoenix program in vietnam that killed
40 000 people
including many innocent people this
isn't this isn't something that makes
these people feel good and they get very
angry
moreover the nation in in the mid 70s
was clearly close to closing down the ci
to rejecting this kind of activity so
they were fighting for their existence
and there you get into the other driving
force of their reaction against
lou wolf and bill shap and myself and
others it's just simply exploitation
working
the thing against
the the people who
there is a theory which is of course
nonsense that phil agee was was sent by
the ci to reveal names to create an
atmosphere which would lead eventually
to an official secrets act now that is
certainly nonsense
and uh in the extent to which it
discredits a very honorable men you know
i
but the fact is that they are exploiting
this revelation of names extensively
to affect the passage of an official
secrets act they were they've tried
every other way over the past 30 years
every other way you could conceive of
they didn't succeed until modern times
and the curious vacillation of the
american
public and washington and the senators
and and
congressmen
in terms of just pure conservatism and
callousness
uh
and i think that american
people really have to understand that it
is their
rights uh who which are being threatened
here now
we are among many people ones who reject
the idea that it's more important to
protect our rights than than people in
other countries
clearly that is not the case
the minute
we are involved in the torture or in the
death of a single person in another
country our rights are being abridged in
our
tax money to say the least is being used
and our humanity is being violated
because we're being asked to accept
inhuman acts perpetuated in our name as
americans
plus the fact that it eventually will
come home they use it successfully
overseas they'll use it on the united
states citizens as well
one of the most
interesting
aspects of this bill and the current
environment in washington
is to project what it
does to the legal system
of free society like ours in terms of
the individual when you begin to give a
special police a secret police a legal
priority legal freedoms and rights over
the citizens we have some examples we
don't have to speculate the bill isn't
passed yet and yet some of the things
that have been happening in the last few
years illustrate what we can look
forward to
for example one to begin with a personal
experience i testified to the senate
a little over a year over a year ago
against this bill i demanded the right
to testify because they had aclu
testifying against it and journalists
but no one who had been inside who knew
about cover and could say this is
[ __ ] i was there we didn't do it
that way
they they acquiesced and let me testify
now you have to write out a written
statement before you testify and submit
it and then you verbally introduce
yourself on the floor of the senate i am
so and so and what
and uh then proceed to make a verbal
statement which parallels the written
statement
the senate
oversight intelligence oversight
committee
submitted my written statement to the
cia for censorship the day before my
testimony
the cia struck out two parts
which were in the public record
published in my book and republished in
many magazines
overt information which both of you have
read and many other people in this
nation forty thousand people or so that
bought my book have read
which was not national security
information but there were two things
that i cited that showed the cia's
disregard for agents cover
it just illustrated the fact that there
was no that they weren't secret agents
the ci struck them out
and returned the report deleting these
points
now
i was meeting with the representatives
of the senate committee just before i
went on to testify
and the senate uh legal counsel the
young attorney
threatened me right outside their office
i didn't have a badge to get inside
their office who were standing in a
little foyer outside and i mean finger
in the chest
you know and i'm warning you john
stockwell do not use the floor of the
senate to challenge cia review
like this and i'm backing up like that
then we walk into the he didn't know
you're an international karate champion
and so then i went in to testify
and i began to introduce myself and jake
garns
from utah
i was saying you know stockpile 19 years
in the marine corps and marine corps
reserves 13 years in the ci the wars and
medals and whatnot to establish the fact
that i you know i have certain
credentials for having served my country
and he interrupted me to say i know who
you are you're a traitor and everything
about you fills me with loathing and
disgust
and i said senator no one is going to
say something like that to me anywhere
and he said i just did i had my freedom
of speech too and grinned at the cameras
and i said yeah but the difference is
that i give you your freedom of speech
and you're trying to take mine away from
me
okay
uh in frank snap's case where the
government sued him to take a civil suit
to take
take away the profits from his book
so-called they took away all the gross
proceeds not just the profits
they took him into the fourth oh yes he
couldn't deduct his typing costs or
whatever they took away the gross of
everything the book had made
now
in the first day of hearing in the
fourth district court under judge orrin
lewis
with
all kinds of attorneys and journalists
attending this thing
orrin lewis made statements
which
the washington post three major
newspapers in the nation were virtually
calling for his impeachment the next day
for the bias of his statements
he said that it would not be necessary
to have a jury that he could handle it
himself
he said that the facts in the case
didn't interest him one damn bit
he said that
it was his objective to take away from
mr snap his quote ill-gotten gains
that was before the trial even this was
the first day this was in the first days
of the thing
highest open mind he did this in front
of like i say 50 attorneys who were
there because of the the
unconstitutional the new law aspect of
the case
and journalists prominent journalists
from all over the world now
the mo that's horrifying but what's much
more horrifying is what follows frank
snep and his attorney were relaxed after
that figuring that whatever happened
they had it won in the appeals because
of his incredibly prejudiced statements
then and throughout the case he kept
interrupting
the the state's council
uh
to to disallow to protest
snep's positions and vice versa i mean
he was conducting the the hearings
now
snap and mark lynch the aclu attorney
working with him felt that they had
absolutely won in the appeals when they
got the court record
to go to the fourth district appeals
court in richmond virginia
those statements had been expunged from
the record
and the the appeals court refused to
address itself to the fact that oran
lewis's prejudicial statements had been
written out the judge had gotten to the
court recorder and told him to type the
thing up without those statements is
that legal what what's the status that's
a pure raw felony
warren lewis and
the
the court recorder whoever did it
should you know should get about 15
years for that but the courts refused to
consider the fact that the court record
had been modified there were 50
witnesses
three newspapers calling for the men's
virtually for the men's impeachment for
his statements and then when they get
there the court record it doesn't say
the same thing that all of these
witnesses said it did afterwards that's
just one example this this also shows
very graphically how if you have these
police agencies like the cia or the fbi
getting out of control how they corrupt
the entire legal system
and then the case of
of phil agee that we mentioned
previously in his passport hearing where
the state is revealing names falsely
claiming these men were killed in order
to prove a point
to get broader legislation for the cia
and then just a little case
that has
no implications in terms of names of
agents bills or whatnot freedom of
speech but it illustrates the point phil
lichtke
quit the cia he was writing a book about
koreagate which i hope he gets published
it's truly a horrifying account of its
own
about the inside story of cor he
submitted it for review as the law
requires him to do
they challenged it
and deleted a lot of things so then he
would write footnotes saying the
information blanked out in the above
paragraphs discusses a high-ranking ci
official
who was taken out by korean police and
gotten drunk
and coerced and
without you know trying to come up with
a footnote and then submit the footnotes
for review and he was truly a thorn in
their side and then they were having to
address themselves to what of the
footnotes could they because you know
they eventually have to defend these
things in court
but anyway he was working on his book
very seriously with them through the
review process
his wife was unstable treated for our
mental problems in
psychiatric treatment
she
they were in the process of getting a
divorce the ci had its councils work
with her and work with her councils
now they claim this was necessary to
prevent her or the divorce proceedings
from revealing national security
information but she wasn't an employee
of the cia
they had prominent ci i mean gs 17 cia
officers
go to the hear the divorce hearings and
testify
against philitsky character
assassination saying things that his
friends would absolutely deny in terms
of his character and his stability
and when he and his attorney tried to
cross-examine them the court said no
because of national security they
couldn't be questioned on the statements
they had made about him and they were
permitted to walk out of the room
without cross-examination
so they could stand up and destroy his
character lying while he did so and walk
away without being cross-examined now
see the the the precedent in that case
means that if the government begins to
come after people like they have to
rewrite the whole legal system if they
begin to prosecute people under the
names of agents bill
they can't you know the citizens defense
of this was the truth this horrible
thing was happening which might make
some points with the jury cannot be
brought out they claim national security
so they will allow government witnesses
to come in and testify
for the prosecution but they will not
allow them to be cross-examined to pull
out the whole truth to defend the
individual this is what we're getting
into with the new law legal libel legal
libel legal slander legal libel legal
slander legal biased information and
depriving
the citizen the defendant of the right
to defend himself
to act to get the full information out
it's a new law it's a new era we're
getting into it's 180 degrees new from
what this country is all about
and again i repeat the irony that the
the beauty of it from the cia's point of
view is that the great mass of the
american people including the press and
the movers of the society are oblivious
of what's happening john we wanted to
thank you for coming on our show to
revealing to our audience here exactly
what's at stake in this name of agent's
bill and we also want to tell you that
next week we have some more revelations
and startling revelations about recent
cia activity with lewis wolf of the
covert action information bulletin who
will be back and john stockwell will
again comment on some of lewis's
revelations we'll have some more updated
stories about the cia so the cia watch
continues on alternative views and now
for some news stories
how many of you have heard of sonoma
state college
well it's in california
and each year they select the 10 most
censored stories of the year
and those who don't quite make the top
10 are considered the old 15 or 20 under
reported stories of the year
how do they select this well they have a
panel mainly a combination of press
and people from the press itself people
from cbs or new york times
and so
since
1976 they've been doing this
and very interestingly every one of
these top ten stories has been covered
by alternative views
mainly because the stories originate or
appear in the alternative press
for instance the basic call this was in
1981 the top story was the basic cause
of our economic crisis monopoly
militarism and multinationalization have
destroyed america's free enterprise
the next story was in justice at
greensboro members of the clan and the
nazis shooting down those
labor leaders there we've covered these
the third one is buying america and
radioactive burying america and
radioactive waste
one hungry one child dies of hunger
every two seconds
and on and on and on anyway these are
all stories that we've covered but
nobody nobody else the one we missed was
one which well it came across in the
chicago tribune i don't like the chicago
tribune i guess you do either
but this is an incredible thing i've
never heard of this before
so this will close the gap and now we've
reported on all stories since 1976
did you know that there is a bank
in the united states government
which will fund
projects
which congress does not approve of or if
congress does approve they only give
them a pittance rather than as much as
they want
and they give a
sample or if the federal or the
executive branch wants to do something
quietly they have this special little
bank which does it for instance
nasa wanted a new satellite to track
other other satellites but it was afraid
that congress wouldn't approve the money
they wanted western union to do it and
they would finance it just hey buddy
here's the money and uh
and the government would it was a
straight loan from the government to
them
this bank is in the office of the
federal treasury building in washington
and was reported back in 1979 the bank
operates with just a handful of staff
members but it has extended some 65
billion dollars in loans since it
started in 1974
and this is more than the total
outstanding loans of the bank of america
the world's largest private bank that's
big bucks
that's incredible
i have an astonishing story here that i
think will be on possibly simona
college's 10 biggest stories that's been
neglected for this year this is a story
that i haven't seen reported on
television or any of the media and it is
the trial that's going on now of the top
chemical testing company in america
called the industrial bio testing
laboratories that is now going on in a
case that in these times in a story on
this alleges is the most massive
scientific fraud in u.s history since
1953 the industrial biotesting
laboratories is the largest corporation
in america that tests all of the
chemicals that are used in herbicides
pesticides that are used on many
different products that we use daily
what these corporations do is they pay
this corporation industrial bio testing
laboratories money to carry out tests to
see if the products that these
corporations want to sell
are safe or not and then the government
takes a look at the tests and certifies
on the basis of these chemical tests
whether a product is or is not safe well
after seven years of government
investigation it appears that there has
been massive scientific fraud in the
testing that the
bio
test laboratories have been carrying out
in other words they've been doing shoddy
scientific research and testing they've
been
covering over dangers in some of the
products that we use falsifying evidence
doing shoddy examination making claims
in tests that they didn't really carry
out
failing to experiment for certain
dangerous chemicals and substances so it
could be that many many products that
are now on the market that went through
this company are dangerous to give you a
sense of the magnitude of what's at
stake here the in these times stories
indicates that over ten thousand ibt
studies have been carried out to
register products for the american
market and at least 2 000 of them are
primary research that no other testing
company or no other government test was
carried through to test the safety of
these con these products
moreover
independent canadian and american
scientists have called the majority of
the studies that this corporation has
carried out to be scientifically invalid
and they claim that almost all of the
insecticides and herbicides that are on
the market today over 325 of them that
were certified by this
company and their test may not be safe
at all so this is a massive scientific
scandal that may have a lot of
importance for us because this may mean
we've been using products that have
really not been safe and this hadn't
been covered at all in the media that
i've seen about even though it seems to
be a major story
the wall street journal reports the
doctors defrauding medicare may face
fines in excess of a hundred thousand
dollars
the health department's inspector
general is readying civil penalties for
doctors who double bill patients are
charged for operations that they never
perform
officials also are investigating
kickback payments by medical equipment
suppliers to hospitals and therapists
there are several good books out on this
subject but one i thought was
particularly good was called tender
loving greed by mary mendelsohn and it
chronicled abuses in the nursing home
industry
and one of the things she says is a big
scam in nursing homes nowadays that
actually has the mob involved in it
is the milking of the medicare profits
by rewriting loans
it seems that the mobs will buy up a
whole chain of nursing homes
and then funnel the medicare and
medicaid money into rewritten loans that
with
interest rates of like 40 percent
so that most of the money instead of
going to the patients themselves in the
form of food and health care is actually
going to the coffers of the mobsters
that's tender loving greed by mary
mendelsohn excellent book
this concludes the first of our
three-part series
on covert action featuring john
stockwell former high cia official and
lewis wolf editor of covert action
information bulletin
alternative views is a production of the
alternative information network p o box
7279 austin texas
78712
good night
you